welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is rohit de an assistant professor of
history at Yale University he is a
historian of modern South Asia and is
particularly interested in legal history
and comparative constitutional law
professor day has assisted Chief Justice
kg Balakrishnan of the Supreme Court of
India and has worked on Constitution
reform projects in Nepal and Sri Lanka
today we'll talk with him about his
forthcoming book the Republic of writs
litigious citizens constitutional law
and everyday life in India which
explores how the Indian Constitution
came to permeate everyday life in India
during its transition from a colonial
state to a democratic republic welcome
professor day thank you and it's great
to be here let's begin with an overview
of your book tell us about it
sure so at its very basic level the book
argues that the Constitution matters now
this might seem fairly obvious if you're
sitting in the US but in the Indian case
this is not something that that's
obvious so India sure India enacted
Constitution in 1953 years after
independence
it's a constitution that's written by a
group of elite nationalist politicians
the deliberations are in English and the
document is in English a language that
at that point was spoken by less than 5%
of the population and why was that
language chosen partly to do with the
fact that the legal system in India and
the British to function in English but
also English was picked up as an
official language for the Indian state
because it's one of those few languages
that actually United at least the elites
of different parts of the country so
even when they were writing the
Constitution the framers particularly
the Chairman the drafting committee dr.
Ambedkar kept referring to the fact that
while these godless Constitution has all
these great ideas it doesn't reflect the
lived experience
of of most of our people so it's not
something that people have charged it by
saying this Constitution was not organic
it didn't carotid the society and I mean
famously one of the members of the
assembly hearing looking at the
Constitution said we wanted the music of
the veena and a sitar but you've played
the music of the English brass band so
note the sense that this is not an
Indian Constitution and a lot of human I
mean human rights scholars and civil
libertarians have pointed out that the
Constitution actually does not
necessarily protect individual rights to
the same extent that other constitutions
do so while the US Constitution was
about protecting the citizens from the
state the Indian Constitution was made
to empower the state to transform
society and economy so all the rights
that are given are limited their various
grounds in which the rights can be
curtailed and the the new independent
state in many ways looked very much like
the colonial state so the judiciary the
police the jail system the bureaucracy
continued to be the same you had
elections and you had a little system on
top but critics have said it's basically
a colonial Constitution with a little
bit of window dressing on it so at a
fundamental level I want at my work
looks that looks at sort of questioning
this proposition to show how it makes a
different indifference in real ways I'm
specifically interested in and and what
the book looks at is how very quickly I
mean within a few years of the country
coming into force it begins to become a
part of everyday life and imagination of
of ordinary people and I I trace this
through looking at court cases that
people bring against the state and and
looking at what sort of people bring
cases and what kind of disputes are
brought and how the the new government
reacts to them right what led you to
write the book so I I trained as a
lawyer in India initially and I and I
worked for a bit with with with the
judge and there's some kind of paradox
that exists and India but also in other
post-colonial countries so on the one
hand you know you have a system which
functions in a language of people who
understand neither the state nor people
necessarily follow the law so very often
in everyday life you see laws are broken
it's not what is conventionally seen as
you know a place where where rules are
followed how
within all of this the Constitution has
a great degree of importance both for
politicians but also ordinary people it
keeps up in everyday conversations there
are multiple issues ultimately go and
get adjudicated by the court and there
is a sense of you know despite all you
know evidence of the contrary there's a
real sense that people continue to
engage with this legal system so that
was sort of the paradox that I grew
interested in okay and then let's
elaborate on on the research you did so
how many how many cases did you look at
I began I mean so part of this I
initially began by looking at going
through a large amount of cases that
appeared in the 1950s I was trying
particularly look at a certain kind of
cases so I was looking for new policies
that the government does as part of its
project of transforming society and
economy and and this is very much the
agenda of the newly independent
government they're trying to show
themselves different from the colonial
state they interested in social welfare
economic development so I was looking at
these new laws and when and and
instances where these new laws are
challenged so by the end when I when I'm
reading the book I've sort of zoned in
on on on certain kinds of kinds of laws
and they cut across different aspects of
everyday life so I look at challenges to
Prohibition in Bombay and prohibition is
an important part of this independent
government's plank it's a promise that's
in the Constitution and it's not only
seen as this is about you know creating
healthy workforce you know preventing
the evils that drink causes in families
but also a real sense that drink was a
foreign you know alcohol was a foreign
sort of poison in India Gandhi spoke
about this very often you know and the
government made lot of revenues out of
selling liquor so the sense this is sort
of tainted revenue and we are going to
stop it and we're also going to curb
Prohibition practices and and this gets
challenged in courts and interesting
ways and so talk about that a little bit
what kind of interesting ways so people
were not happy that they weren't going
to be able to drink anymore of course
you know a vast number of people
continued to drink anyway there
there was bootlegging and just like like
in the US in the 20s and 30s but what
was interesting is almost as soon as the
constitute prohibition goes into force a
year before the Constitution as soon as
the Constitution goes into force a
public spirited citizens sort of walks
to court and says this new law violates
my fundamental rights to Liberty and the
property under the Constitution and he
argues for instance that he makes he
makes a range of arguments but he points
out for instance that the fact that the
states creates exception so the
prohibition law allowed foreigners and
the army to continue to drink and I mean
a lot of the argument was about how can
you treat these two groups differently
you have to treat all Indians equally so
this violates the right to equality and
the courts took this very seriously and
there was a lot of public interest in
this but what was interesting to me is
not that this man went to court but how
surprised the government was so in a way
the independent government never really
thought that its products are going to
be challenged in court like this there
was a real sense that we are you know
after after hundreds of years a
democratically elected government
representing the will of the people and
now we have you know this sort of pesky
individual who comes up to the court so
the court sort of struggles to balance
you know clearly a democratic
governments mandate and this individual
and ultimately says when you can have
prohibition but you can't sort of ban
alcohol in all its forms so one of the
things the government had did was than
words it even said things like if you
had medicine without call in it or a
mouthwash with alcohol in it that would
also be illegal and prohibited so you
would think ordinarily this is not a big
victory you know the state wins either
in a small loophole but then I find all
these cases where they arrest people who
have been driving and they say we can
smell alcohol on your breath and the
individual claims well I just had
mouthwash so I had medicinal wine and
there's almost no way to sort of prove
that they didn't right and there's an
explosion in the production of these
commodities because of this one small
loophole that this individual has has
garv doubt so it's also story about you
know there's a dimensionality of how we
imagine court cases to function you go
in and you win a right or you don't win
a right but very often it's not about
winning in court it's about what
possibilities that opens up and what
loopholes become available so by the
sixties the government Bombay had to
sort of wind up its prohibition program
because there was so many sort of
loopholes picked in and and there's
constant litigation about what these
glucose as well all of which were sort
of relying on certain basic
constitutional principles okay
interesting so what so what other ways
has the Indian Constitution come to
dominate public life sure so there's a
couple of other specific examples sure
so I mean um just to give you I mean a
little bit of how the Indian
Constitution works now I mean it's a
document it's something that that's been
amended a fair number of times but India
today has one of the world's most
powerful Supreme Court's it's a courts
that sort of that's appropriated several
powers to itself over the years it's
withstood challenges from the executive
the court can review legislation create
it has created new rights it has also in
some cases sort of legislated policy
from the courts it appoints its own
judges and all of this is because
there's a sense that there is
constitutional domain that it's very
hard for the politicians to interfere so
it's it's become you know almost a
separate field of politics in itself
most major policy decisions end up being
taken to the court so I mean humourous
would say it's basically Supreme Court
of India that runs runs the country
except for when you know the elections
take place but more broadly in the
period I'm looking at what's interesting
is this is not this is not this has not
yet happened there's a new system as we
put into place and people aren't sure
what the rules are going to be or how
this new object of the Constitution is
going to work because we're talking
about so I what what happens fairly
quickly is that it becomes both sort of
a organizing assumption so when people
are making decisions when businessmen
are making policies when housewives are
going shopping when so there's a sense
that you know that the system exists and
there is there is a way through which
you can work through it so it helps you
take your decisions
quite soon for the government the
Constitution becomes sort of a threat so
now they began to almost anticipate
within four or five years they begin to
anticipate constitutional challenges and
keep trying to find ways of you know
creating this bulletproof law that
cannot be taken to court but invariably
always is so so it's a period of which
begins with uncertainty and and I think
that's what keeps it going so it's not
as if the Constitution is necessarily
liberating for the general public or
necessarily oppressive neither side
really knows what's going to happen but
it's clear that it can really change
things so it influences how people lead
the daily lives in many ways I mean it
is interesting because it is a brand new
document for one - it's it's not in a
language that most people understand and
that really interests me because because
it sounds like the common everyday
person is like you know getting the
Constitution and reading through it but
yet they don't under they cannot read
English so how is that happening so I
mean the the part that - two bits two
puzzles one of course is the role that
lawyers play so India compared to
several other British colonies the time
really has a large number of lawyers
okay a many familiar world in the
nationalist movement but most of them
are just people who are you know working
and working in a town urban legend
looking to make raising income when the
Constitution comes into force initially
it's quite instrumental so a client
comes to you with a problem the argument
is the government shutting my shop down
previously you could have done you had
options a B and C but now you have this
new option of the Constitution so
there's a real sense that lawyers become
in a way missionaries for the
Constitution and I've chased a little
bit about how this legal knowledge
spread so looking at law publishing and
circulation of textbooks I mean the
other story clearly here is that of the
media so trials make the news so even if
people don't read the Constitution
either the read a newspaper or in India
it's it's quite common that someone
reads out the newspaper to them in a
public space so every newspaper is not
just read by someone who buys it but
there's also another group that gets
exposure to it so many of the cases they
look at become sort of big media stories
and you see cases following very quickly
so
one of the cases I see involves a
vegetable vendor in a small town in
North India who finds this new way of
challenging municipal regulations and
within the next few months you start
noticing in all the neighboring towns
so the vegetable vendors making the same
argument so clearly new spreads and
people learn that there's new tactic to
do it you also talk about certain
marginal groups and how the
constitutional culture in the 50s was
shaped by them talk a little bit about
the groups and and how they shapes sure
so as you can imagine I mean much of the
critique of law everywhere is that law
is a tool that's used by the rich and
and the wealthy and even in Indian cases
a significant number of people who go to
court are middle class or or wealthy and
but what surprised me was there was a
substantial it's a minority but a
substantial minority of groups who you
would think of as marginal at our border
and so just to name a few
they're butchers they're vegetable
vendors prostitutes or women who go up
and very clearly say via prostitutes
beggars people who were clearly
smuggling people who mark this criminal
of some kind and in a way one of the
arguments I make is that what we take is
some of the principles of
constitutionalism really get shaped
through through these cases so for
instance the idea that the government
can't delegate unrestricted Authority to
a magistrate in a town so the my
distress authority must have certain
curbs to it and the reason why it
happens through these cases is very
often these individuals go in and they
make a claim to a right and the to light
the right the right really isn't carried
through is for example on prostitutes go
in and they challenge a new
anti-prostitution law by saying there's
the Constitution guarantees us a right
to trade in profession prostitution is
the world's oldest profession you have
to have my rights protected is
prostitution legal in India you can as
an individual engage as a woman said
engaging services but what's illegal or
what was illegal 50s was both soliciting
so I organized prostitution but the way
the law was crafted was
if there was a space where there's more
than one woman engaging in prostitution
it is a brothel and therefore his
organized Constitution so one of the
women that I look at comes to court and
says I am a prostitute and and so is my
sister and we live in the same house so
effect and and and in the house live my
mother and my children and this new law
has converted them into criminals as
well because they're living off the
earnings of prostitution and it's
converted my house into criminal space
so I'm you know I can't practice my
profession if you if I can't stay in my
house so there was a real sense that
this new law this this this right the
profession has no meaning because
effective this new law is shutting it
down which is what the frick reform was
actually intended and they were
horrified when women like a host a bar
in this case dumped a court and make
these claims the courts are very
conflicted and and eventually the whole
well while prostitution you have a right
to practice prostitution to prostitution
it cannot overcome sort of the state's
interests in protecting health and
morality
so that right doesn't hold but what
really works in these cases because
their rights claims isn't working is
that they make a claim about how
government should follow certain kind of
process in a republic so this is
democratic government it's bound by
rules you cannot have disaggregated
power given to a bureaucrat or to a
local magistrate so I mean the
prostitution laws your local officer
could decide any decide that this woman
is prostitute and ask her to sort of
leave leave the neighborhood and the
courts sort of start regulating the
behavior of these office bearers so they
say the strict guideline is what you can
do there's certain about description you
can follow and then these are these
procedures then become followed in other
instances well when cases involve you
know businessmen or or or citizens who
are not engaged in you know marginal
professions so in a way that these rules
get worked out in these hard cases it
must be I mean an overwhelming amount of
work to you know to hear these cases and
then create all of those rules it seems
mind-boggling almost for the judiciary
yeah yes and that's one of the reasons
why the Indian legal system is right for
delays so it's always it has always been
a problem cases take a long time and
today I mean once the teacher
a couple of years said that if the
Supreme Court had to clear all the cases
they had at the moment it would take 20
to 30 years and this is when they here I
mean they give about twenty twelve I
mean I'm not sure what the exact figure
is but they hear about thousands of
cases every year as opposed to the
hundreds a the US Supreme Court hears
but in the 50s they weren't that
overburdened and again this is why the
Constitution becomes important is if
you're filing a constitutional case a
writ petition you get to jump the queue
so in many cases supposing you're a
woman who is being evicted by the town
because they suspect that you're a
prostitute you would file a civil suit
of some kind and that would take fifteen
years to get decided and it would cost a
lot but if you file a constitutional
fundamental rights petition you jumped
you and you get hurt in a couple of
weeks so why didn't everyone do that
then they did and this is sort of a
rapid sort of sort of shift to it I
don't look into it very much but a lot
of lawyers try to convert income tax
cases into fundamental rights cases and
the courts try to clamp it down but the
real litigation explosion happens about
about about 20 years later so 50 is
still the court seem to be managing and
delivering so what about in doing your
research did you come across anything
that shocked you or surprised you they
just didn't expect lot so perhaps I
shouldn't about how my research was - so
ordinarily the Constitution - I didn't
India studied by lawyers who read
judgments so these are published and
available in the library but as a
historian of the option looking at a
larger world around these cases so
looking for the original case files
themselves which was supposed to be
there in court and it took me I mean the
the while the courts hold these files
they have not been used in archives so
it takes a lot a lot of persuasion to
actually get access to it and and being
a lawyer I went in thinking that this
was you know easy story right you go to
court and you file a challenge and you
know this is a clever way of winning but
just working in the court and as someone
who went in with access the difficulties
that even I faced trying to get hold of
documents
realize how tough it must have been for
these litigants oh the fact that they
went to court it's not
it wasn't easy decision to make it was a
hard decision in the fact that they went
up all the way and they won meant that
you know they really invested time
effort and energy into making that
happen
so what seemed to have been an obvious
story for me actually became a more
interesting more complex story what was
also surprising is that a lot of cases
it seemed to be a case brought by an
individual I mean just looking at the
material around seemed to be it's
actually a case being brought by a group
so again to go back to this case
involving a prostitute that two cases
file in two different cities on the same
day both by these virtually identical
cases of these women who say we live in
this household and we live with family
member and this law is making it
impossible for us to live but
simultaneously you hear the story of in
the paper about a dancing girls Union
that's being formed and police reports
about how women in red-light districts
are collecting money from customers to
file a lawsuit so there's a sense that
this is actually a community of
prostitutes who are organizing to sort
of take the state to court and then I
got interested as to and this happened
in several of my cases so so why do
certain why a certain marginal groups
able to organize and come through so I
found two elements to it one of course
is a sort of counterintuitive so you
don't see peasants of farmers coming to
court in large numbers you don't see
middle-class women coming to court in
large numbers but you see these sort of
people who on the edges of of the of the
economy edge of society coming in and
and I think partly this is because in
some ways they have higher legal
consciousness so for years they've been
regulated by the state in many ways as a
street vendor or a beggar a prostitute
you deal with many more regulations then
middle-class housewife you you have
contact with the police
you have gone you've probably had to
hire a lawyer in the past so in a way
it's easier for you to move and secondly
for the story about caste which so
several of these groups are professional
groups and they often belong to the same
caste so there's a sense that the caste
allows you forms a network which allows
the information to flow and in some
cases actually gives you resources to
fight the case so the butchers who
organize their 3,000 butchers and they
all belong to the same community
and it's clear the communities
organizing the sort of challenge
challenge this law okay final question
how does the Constitution of the 1950s
compare with the Constitution in India
today that's that's a good question and
it's something that I'm stated sort of
pulling out other groups I think while
fifties are interesting is it's a moment
of uncertainty and it's a moment of
dealing with a new system so no one I
mean neither the judges nor the
government nor the litigants really knew
what was going to happen once a case
when it took court rules are being
formulated all the time so it's a sense
of of a new system being created and
today we know what the answer is today
there is a sense that the Indian
Constitution it's so the Supreme Court
is very powerful it's hard for the
government to sort of change things
there are delays built in the system all
of these weren't sort of evidence there
initially
very often when the court would make a
decision it went against the government
the government try to overturn the
decision by either changing policy or
even amending the Constitution they've
sort of stopped doing that now because
those rules have been built in but also
the 50s there's a sense that I mean the
courts are emptier it's easier to fight
cases and there's a real sense of
possibility which I find sort of sort of
refreshing to go back go back go back
and look at very good well this has been
fascinating thank you so much for being
here today and sharing some of your work
thanks man
for more information about Professor day
and his research please visit our
website at yale.edu slash McMillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McMillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale